[Música]
es un gusto estar con ustedes Soy Paula
Jiménez Correa y les doy la bienvenida
Así es Asia el magacín quincenal de
France 24 que aborda las múltiples
realidades de este continente Estos son
nuestros titulares
China y filipinas protagonizaron el más
reciente episodio de detención en el sur
de Asia tras denunciarse mutuamente de
realizar maniobras peligrosas en el mar
de China meridional donde ambos países
se disputan la soberanía de algunos
territorios
y ahora que India es el país más poblado
del mundo ha sobrepasar a China Cuáles
son los retos que enfrentará en materia
económica sanitaria de vivienda y
educación para los próximos años
tendremos o trataremos de responder
estos interrogantes en esta edición
Nos dirigimos a nepal que alberga quitar
la pista de aterrizaje más peligrosa del
mundo el aeropuerto de lucla en medio de
las montañas cuenta con tan solo 460
metros de largo en el que los
aterrizajes complicados son una parte
arriesgada pero vital de la vida
cotidiana
iniciamos este recorrido en la región de
Asia Pacífico que sigue sumando
capítulos de tensión con dos actores en
común China y Estados Unidos
recientemente filipinas denunció que
barco chinos realizaron maniobras
peligrosas en territorios disputados en
el mar de China meridional algo que el
gobierno de Beijing negó a sostener que
solo estaban defendiendo la soberanía
nacional del país en este punto hablamos
de la soberanía del arrecife de
escalburu o también llamado bajo de
massinglock y parte del archipiélago que
ambos países reclaman como suyos todo
esto días después de los ejercicios
militares conjuntos entre filipinas y
Estados Unidos que fueron calificados
como los más grandes de su historia y
que se extendieron por dos semanas y que
como era de esperarse Fueron rechazados
por el gobierno chino
para analizar los pormenores de esta
atención tenemos a Javier alcalde
profesor de relaciones internacionales
de la Universidad Católica de Perú señor
alcalde Muchas gracias por aceptar esta
invitación y empiezo preguntándole
Cuáles son los intereses tanto de China
como de Filipinas en el mar de China
meridional escenario de la reciente
extensiones marítimas entre estos dos
países
bueno los intereses de China son los de
reclamar soberanía en gran parte de el
mar meridional ellos consideran que para
ellos este mares algo así como el Caribe
para Estados Unidos un lago desde cada
uno en cuanto a filipinas quiere que se
reconozca los derechos que tiene en
algunas Islas
ahora el otro interés de Filipinas es
acercarse a Estados Unidos y recibir
apoyo de la comunidad de negocios
norteamericana para poder salir del
bajón que sufrió su economía a raíz del
covid hace ya unos años
recientemente vimos El encuentro entre
el presidente filipinas ferdinan Marcos
Junior con su homólogo de Estados Unidos
Joe biden en la casa blanca quien le
prometió más ayuda militar teniendo en
cuenta que manila es un Aliado
estratégico de Washington en la región
En qué consiste ese convenio acordado en
materia de seguridad y De qué manera
aumenta la tensión con China
bueno en primer lugar no creo que este
convenio tenga las características
formales de una alianza entonces
consistía en el apoyo probablemente de
barcos norteamericanos se van a estar
posicionados en el mar de la china
meridional No ahora Claro que esto pueda
desencadenar una confundación mayor es
algo que no se puede
prever no pero ciertamente
Estados Unidos china va a tener que ser
un poco más cauta en su encuentro con
buques de Filipinas porque sabe que hay
siempre el riesgo de una confrontación
mayor con Estados Unidos que además está
ansioso de mostrar ante los países del
sudeste asiático que puede sacar la cara
por ellos
que es un Partner de de confianza
hablando en términos de cercanía
geográfica puede filipinas convertirse
en un Aliado crucial para Estados Unidos
ante una eventual invasión de China a
Taiwán
hay que tener en cuenta claro Hay un
factor cercanía Pero en cuanto a las
capacidades de de Filipinas yo creo que
no son espectaculares no lo que yo tengo
entendido es que Estados Unidos cuenta
en caso de una invasión china a Taiwán
con Australia el base una base muy
grande de inteligencia Y con
lanzamisiles cerca Darwin eso podría ser
utilizado para atacar a China para
repeler la inversión a Taiwán Por
supuesto que esto es muy importante
porque podría haber podría haber barcos
americanos mucho más cerca no pero
yo creo que hay que poner las cosas en
en su dimensión
no filipinas no es una ni siquiera una
mediana potencia militar no que pueda
dar un apoyo muy activo No acá lo
importante es repito la situación de las
bases y el hecho que china va a tener
cuidado porque no quiere presentar una
crisis ahora en caso de que ocurra la
invasión de Taiwán
no sé si sería crucial esto pero sí
ayudaría bastante teniendo en cuenta que
se trata de una un nuevo hace tú unos
nuevos activos norteamericanos
relativamente cerca a a Taiwán
agradecemos al Señor alcalde por su
análisis vamos a India donde las horas
de población implica grandes desafíos en
políticas públicas según la ONU India
sobre China y es ahora el país más
poblado del mundo desde finales de abril
con más de 1.425 millones de habitantes
en el campo y en la ciudad esta cifra se
evidencia en la falta de oportunidades
laborales y de Educación así como en el
costo de la vivienda y en el sistema de
salud Samuel Salgado nos tiene la
historia
en las orillas de Río yamuna principal
la fuente de Nueva Delhi atestigua la
sobrepoblación en India sus habitantes
se están asfixiando con aguas residuales
y basura un reto en materia sanitaria
Tratamos de sobrevivir aquí en medio de
los malos olores la contaminación el
principal problema es que no hay
limpieza
los niños de silampur sufren
enfermedades como la disentería debido a
la incapacidad del gobierno en el
tratamiento de los desechos más de
55.000 niños murieron en 2019 por
problemas intestinales
45.000 millones de litros de agua
residuales generados al día en los
centros urbanos el equivalente a 18.000
piscinas olímpicas no son tratados
con los ahora más de 1.425 millones de
habitantes India se convirtió en el país
más poblado del mundo a finales de abril
según la organización de Naciones Unidas
por lo que la sobrepoblación es un
desafío en materia de políticas públicas
su jetcumar tiene 21 años dejó el campo
donde el acceso a la educación es bajo
para estudiar en bombay y participar del
auge económico que se concentra en las
zonas urbanas hay mucho desempleo en mi
pueblo la gente Simplemente no puede
arreglárselas con el dinero que se gana
pero la migración masiva bombay ciudad
de casi 27 millones de habitantes está
aumentando la Competencia por la Tierra
y la presión sobre la infraestructura y
vivienda en algunos barrios el valor de
alquiler por metro cuadrado ha alcanzado
los 11.000 dólares una suma de dinero
imposible de pagar para la mayoría de la
población muy por detrás del segundo
país más poblado china el producto
interno bruto es de 2 dólares por
persona en India y alrededor del 80% de
los trabajadores están en la
informalidad
el estado Confía en que la población
disminuirá sin necesidad de políticas de
control de natalidad
pienso que India no necesita replicar la
política de control de natalidad de
china en algunos estados la tasa de
natalidad va en Rápido descenso y está
por debajo del umbral de 2,1 hijos por
familia
Pero según el Banco Mundial las brechas
de desigualdad entre la población India
aumentarán debido a la sobrepoblación
con un 40% de indios viviendo en
ciudades en 2036
de aterrizaje más peligrosa del mundo
lo de lucra en nepal es una experiencia
que ahorra tiempo pero también pone a
prueba los nervios el aeropuerto está
ubicado en medio de las montañas y solo
está abierto cuando el clima lo permite
pero tanto para locales como para
visitantes vale la pena el riesgo veamos
por qué
acercándose al destino y en la distancia
todo lo que hay es una pequeña pista
a 2.800 metros de altura en el Himalaya
el aeropuerto de lucla es pequeño e
inclinado mide 460 metros de largo y
tiene una inclinación de 12 grados
es difícil por muchas razones por el
clima cambiante y también por la gran
altitud Así que aquí también se trata
del rendimiento del motor Así que hay
muchos desafíos Pero también es un poco
emocionante
y despegar también hace parte de estos
desafíos la pista termina al borde de
una cantidad
la pendiente descendente en realidad nos
ayuda a ganar velocidad pero luego
debido a cualquier emergencia en México
porque no queremos adentrarnos en el
terreno queremos escapar
construido en 1964 en este aeropuerto ha
habido varios accidentes
el último ocurrió en 2019 cuando un
avión se estrelló contra un helicóptero
cercano dos años antes otro avión perdió
la pista en su descenso y se estrelló
contra la ladera de la montaña
la mayoría de los turistas que vuelan
aquí están de camino al monte
es impresionante que logren aterrizar en
esta pista tan corta
no soy una persona que le tenga miedo a
los aviones pero aquí es imposible no
tener un poco de miedo miras a un lado
ves montañas muy cerca de ellos y el
carril de aterrizaje es corto por lo que
da miedo
los de la torre de control deciden cada
mañana si hace buen tiempo o no para
abrir la pista de aterrizaje
necesitamos 5 km de visibilidad para
abrir el aeropuerto y por seguridad de
las aeronaves por ser reglas de vuelo
visual no pueden aterrizar con menos de
esa visibilidad sería difícil para ellos
no se puede llegar al pueblo en
automóvil lo que significa que también
se transportan alimentos y otros bienes
geométrica
aquí hay medicamentos galletas
cigarrillos y ropa de cama
si no fuera por los aviones tendríamos
que traer todo en burro
luego las mercancías se transportan a
través de la montaña este hombre está
levantando 100 kilos en su espalda
probablemente piensen que esto es
difícil pero esto es fácil para mí
estamos acostumbrados Me alegro de poder
conseguir trabajo de esta manera
[Música]
todo es parte de la vida diaria de los
residentes de lucla
y para el cierre les dejo estos datos
China India pangadesh e Indonesia son
los mayores productores de arroz en todo
el mundo es decir que más del 60% de
este cereal vendido se origina en Asia
llegamos al final de esta edición de Así
es Asia Muchas gracias por acompañarnos
y los invito a enviar sus comentarios en
la cuenta de Twitter que aparece en sus
pantallas y a seguir toda la información
en nuestra página web trans24.com y no
olviden nuestra cita quincenal
[Música]